everything comes to he who waits so this
was another one that was this was a
patron sponsored review and it's
something a little bit different and it
might no promises yet but it might
become a new occasional series almost
kind of an antidote to something like
good movie bad ending calling it silver
linings and this is me talking about a
movie that I know is not good but I
still really like and pointing out the
things that are kind of great about it
and this gives me the opportunity to
talk about a piece of my childhood the
Masters of the Universe movie from the
80s
starring Dolph Lundgren as he-man oh
okay
so maybe a little bit of background for
my sort of history with this property I
was very into he-man when I was young I
was into the toys more than anything
else I did watch the show it was one of
several shows that my grandmother used
to tape for me cuz she had cable I my
mother didn't even have the rabbit ear
set up on the TV we just had VHS is so
my grandmother would tape off the TV all
of my favorite shows and send them to
and send those to me so I you know I
kind of saw the same episodes over and
over and over again and I like T man I
always did but I always got way more
mileage out of the toys and I think
ultimately I look back on the little
mini comics with more nostalgia than the
actual episodes of the TV show it
doesn't hurt that I think the many
comics hold up better than the episodes
of the TV show do but so in that in that
way right off the bat I actually did
enjoy this film first time I saw it I
didn't see it in the in the theaters but
I remember I had I was renting it
regularly and my mother eventually just
bought me a copy this was back when that
buying VHS was like 30 bucks
in 80's money so not an inexpensive
proposition but I kept renting it over
and over again so she bought me a copy
and I and I know in hindsight because I
didn't really know at the time Internet
wasn't a thing yet but I know a lot of
fans didn't like it because of how much
it different from the TV show and it
does but it bears a closer resemblance
overall to the many comics which
ultimately I kind of liked better and by
that I mean there's no Prince Adam
there's no secret identity there's a
whole bunch of stuff that was unique to
the show that just isn't there instead
he man is just he-man wandering warrior
defender of Eternia he-man and so that's
that's what we get now since this is
gonna be mostly a positive thing and me
talking about the things I love about
this film allow me to acknowledge the
problem so where that an acknowledge of
them up front this was made by Canon
films and Canon films in the eighties I
batting and you know was a golan-globus
production they their whole thing was
trying to make be trying to make a movie
blockbusters on b-movie budgets and you
could tell how much they didn't spend on
most of their prod on most of their
projects I do find this one to be kind
of unique in the golan-globus Cannon
Films scheme of things though and by
that I mean most Canon films are at
least the ones that I've seen I am a
seen a ton they tended to just stretch
their budgets very thin they took
whatever money they had stretched it out
over the length of the film the whole
film just kind of looks not very
expensive what they did in he-man
instead was to spend the money very
selectively and there's a whole bunch of
things that they did that was very
obviously done as cost-cutting
techniques so like for instance instead
of a small army of unique you know
monsters and henchmen you know
characters like Merman and trap-jaw and
and all these these unique looking
henchman for Skeletor to have instead he
has a handful of specific henchmen and
then the rest is just a sea of generic
stormtrooper knockoffs except they're in
black instead of white
that was a cost-cutting measure because
that was cheaper to do than to give
every husband a unique look about half
of the film is set on earth in easily
acquired cheap to shoot in locations
like warehouses and gymnasiums and you
know cheap looking apartments and things
of that nature and then the the few
scenes we see in each other there's
really effectively only three locations
that we see in Eternia at all so you can
see very clearly where the cost-cutting
was done however what they spent the
money on they didn't they went all in on
Newton so it wasn't a matter of it all
looks cheap what they spent money on I'd
say they spent it pretty well the
practical effects we do get on the
various creatures like beast man like
the original characters of people like
kargh and sod and of course the makeup
on Skeletor himself I actually really
loved I'm still astounded by that makeup
what I love about the makeup on
Skeletor is that while it is not
necessarily going to pass for just being
a skull it's a little you know it's a -
Bucky skies a little too much movement
it is incredibly evocative of a skull
but more to the point it looks hard it
looks like if you hit it it would you
know it would clunk it would knock but
he has enough movement in the face to
give a pretty full performance and it
doesn't appear to him peed the
performance that Frank Langella s
Skeletor is able to give and I still
don't really know how they did that and
and the the interior the sort of throne
room space of the interior of Castle
Grayskull that's
phenomenal said that's a huge set took
up two sound stages it's epic but some
of the other problems with it before I
get into the stuff that I love and will
always love so Dolph Lundgren is he-man
kind of works and kind of doesn't he
looks the part pretty well at this point
I don't think he was quite ready for
primetime in terms of being a lead
because he's a little bit of a charisma
vacuum and he can't seem to settle on
what his accent is he's not he's not
awful and again he looks the part well
enough but he doesn't he's not
particularly magnetic it does help that
he has decent chemistry with say Teela
and man-at-arms which are not amazingly
performed but the three of them have
good chemistry together so that helps
the action is not particularly well
filmed it's decently choreographed but
it's shot competently unimpressive Lee
it's not shot in a way to really for the
fight choreography that they have a
better cinematography on the fight
scenes could have really given something
we have these tagged on characters I
mentioned some of the villains that are
unique to this movie which I can just
kind of short off they're like it's fine
because they're consistent with the
kinds of villains that Skeletor had in
the in the TV show and in the comics but
we we lose Orko and we get grilled or
instead I think that's a fair compromise
there was no way they could have
afforded to realise Orko accurately and
closed doors Billy Barty and I liked
Billy Barty a lot but we also get these
because a big chunk of it is set on
earth we get the human teenage
characters of Kevin and Julie with Julie
being played by a young Courtney Cox and
the name of the guy who plays Kevin is
escaping me at the moment but he was
Paris on Star Trek Voyager
now I would actually argue that they
kind of lucked out with those two that
they both that none of them give
phenomenal performances but they do give
off that these people that they
gonna have careers after that they're
gonna be okay they give off that vibe
they give up them this is an early step
in somebody who's gonna have a decent
enough career and that helps a little
but again you know who watches a master
of the universe movie for a couple of
teenagers from Earth nobody that's who
so even though they're fine for what
they are what they are is not what
anyone's there to see James Tolkien is
in it who most people know as the tough
principle from the Back to the Future
movies he was he was kind of an ad
staple and he is always awesome he just
plays a cop and he's great but the one
other thing that I want to acknowledge
just because I do think it is worth
acknowledging these things because I
know it is a deal breaker for some
people the director of this film Gary
Goddard who's had an odd career because
this was really his only theatrically
released film most of what he made is
his career on since then has been theme
park rides that incorporates some degree
of video elements you know things like
the Back to the Future ride and things
like that he might have been involved in
the Terminator ride as well I don't know
I don't have a list off the top of my
head of which ones he did but the reason
I want to bring it up is the fact that
he he is one of a number of people in
the last few years who has been accused
by more than one individual of molesting
in this case young men boys some time
ago I think possibly passed the statute
of limitations I didn't I didn't look up
the specifics cuz honestly they kind of
skeeve me but last I remember checking
he was being sued he was being taken to
civil court because the statute of
limitations for criminal charges had
passed so if you're someone who cannot
stomach watching the films of Roman
Polanski or you know anything with Bill
Cosby or you know things like that
be aware that that is regrettably an
element in this in my part you know I
kind of square that circle by I've you
know I had the VHS and I bought the DVD
a long time before I knew that I already
paid what I'm gonna pay and contributed
you know money to this man and if I'd
known before I pay that money maybe I
wouldn't have but at this point I
already own it and it is nostalgia it is
a big part of my childhood so I have
rewashed it since that stuff came out
and it has I think it helps that he's
the director or not he's not a face I
have to look at so it helps me be able
to still enjoy this but I did just want
to acknowledge that reality of it so
that's you know touching on a couple of
the good stuff but that's mainly me
talking about what's not especially good
about this movie so what's the silver
lining well I may I mentioned it earlier
but let's get into it
Frank Langella as Skeletor oh my god
so Frank Langella had I think he said
this was one of his favorite parts he
ever got to play with how over-the-top
he got to be and I would say this is
right up there with Tim Curry playing
darkness in legend for an actor who is
able to go who is buried you know in
this elaborate makeup but is able to go
so big that he doesn't disappear behind
the makeup that we don't lose the
performance that he doesn't feel like
he's struggling to be seen from behind
it he dominates the screen whenever he's
on it he and he reads these lines like
it's Shakespeare heck they actually give
him a line lifted out of Shakespeare and
lift it out of Richard the third
for crying out loud and I love that I I
don't know if this is the case but
pardon me really does wonder like was
that always in the script or did they
add that when they realized how Frank
Langella was gonna play this and it's so
good and in my mind like that is the
Skeletor voice like if I reread those
old mini comics which
still got some of that's why here I
don't hear the you know the high-pitched
he man I don't hear that anymore that
has a loser
this Skeletor is not a loser he's
intimidating actually as the film starts
he's already won and it makes him
because that was one of the things about
the TV show he was always trying to
upset the status quo but he was always
on the backfoot he was the troublemaker
who didn't make very much trouble at the
end of the day here he's won he has the
power and team and his friends who are
completely on the back foot and it's it
is earned everything about him his voice
is the way he carries himself his
interactions I love him with evil-lyn
meg Foster okay this woman the way that
they visualized Evelyn is really cool
first of all just looks neat but I was
knocked on my butt when I found out that
her eyes are not contacts how was this
woman not cast as a witch or a sorcerer
as prior to this film I will never know
cuz you look at those eyes and it is the
epitome of hypnotic and she has a very
interesting and intriguing presence in
addition to that especially when she has
scenes opposite Frank Langella and
Skeletor is well utilized across this
movie he-man is only in the same room
with him at the very beginning at the
very end but we still get sprinklings of
him throughout so he is the best thing
about the movie and he we get doses of
him as we go which means that the best
thing about the movie is not something
that you have withheld from you for the
majority of the runtime you get but you
get you know you see it on the strany
and you continue to follow it through
the rest of the film and through its
weaknesses because as I said that there
is there is from any objective measure a
lot about this movie that
isn't good I would argue for the
limitations that it had on it in terms
of the budget and who was making it and
the fact that going Globus actually
tried to shut it down before it was even
finished filming they weren't even gonna
have a final fight which is why that
last fight takes place in this weird
pitch-black almost sort of nether realm
it's because they actually couldn't get
back onto the set they had to rig up
like a storage warehouse like I'm
somebody's garage practically to fake it
so that they could get that last fight
it so under the circumstances I think
it's an impressive piece of work knowing
the limitations of it and if you have
not seen Frank Langella s Skeletor for
that alone that is the overriding silver
lining of this thing and it's the reason
I kept coming back to it it's the reason
I still love it now and everything else
I still have affection for but that is
the one thing I would point do and go no
matter what you don't have to like this
movie but I will not hear a bad word
against Frank Langella Skeletor he is
the silver lining of this film and it's
why I love it so much there are other
things I like to but at the end of the
day that is it he's the best thing about
a emitted Li not great movie that I
still love so masters of the universe
from the 80s have you seen it what did
you think about it again I will not hear
a bad word against Frank Langella no
seriously whatever you thought it's fine
um so drop something down on the
comments let's talk about there's all
the stuff to do you know what it is you
don't mean me to tell you it's all down
on the description patrons the big one I
will mention that but you know until
next time Council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]